artificial intelligence use and
acceptance are expanding rapidly over
the past few years artificial
intelligence applications have
considerably advanced and they are now
used practically in every industry you
will learn in detail about the best
real-world uses of artificial
intelligence from this video before
moving forward please make sure you
subscribe to our channel and press the
bell icon to never miss any updates from
simply learn
today's agenda is
first we will understand
what is artificial intelligence next is
top 10 applications of artificial
intelligence and finally conclusion to
the topic
so what let me ask you a question which
are the powerful ai assistance that you
have come across please leave your
answer in the comment section below and
stay tuned to get the answer
moving on what is artificial
intelligence artificial intelligence is
a branch of computer science that
focuses on building smart machines that
can imitate human behavior the
definition of intelligent machine in
this context is a machine that can act
and think like a human and also is
capable of making decisions
so what are the top 10 applications of
artificial intelligence
social media today ai can create social
media post for you it can draft and
target social ads
it can also automate monitoring
and it has powers that most of what you
see in any given social network
facebook's picture recognition tools
have been popular among users for a
while but the company is constantly
working to make the algorithms better so
that users can browse photos without
relying on tags or other nearby
information it will help to tag people
in photos
twitter
understanding what tweets to recommend
to users on their timelines is one of
the numerous ways twitter employs ai on
its platform it seeks to provide users
with the most relevant tweets possible
for individualized experience twitter
also uses ai to combat offensive
statements
instagram artificial intelligence is
used by the platform to improve user
experience filter spam and increase the
effectiveness of targeted advertising
users in the platform can search images
of a specific activity when you event
restaurant food and discovery
experiences
with the aid of tags and trending
information
automobiles the automotive value chain
which includes manufacturing design
supply production post production
driving assistance and driver risk
assessment systems is successfully
implementing artificial intelligence
tesla keeps an eye on the driver's eyes
to detect signs of drowsiness and keep
them from dozing off while operating a
vehicle it is primarily used by the
autopilot system to stop drivers from
taking quick power naps while driving
agriculture
forbes reports that global spending on
smart agriculture including artificial
intelligence and machine learning is
projected to triple to
15.3 million dollars by 2025. precision
agriculture often known as artificial
intelligence systems is assisting in
enhancing the overall quality and
accuracy of harvest artificial
intelligence technology aids in the
detection of pest plant diseases and
under nutrition in farms artificial
intelligence sensors can identify and
target plants before deciding which
herbicide to use in the area
artificial intelligence in gaming the
gaming industry is one another area
where artificial intelligence
technologies have gained popularity
artificial intelligence can be utilized
to develop intelligent human-like
non-person characters that can
communicate with the players
in order to improve game design and
testing it can also be used to forecast
human behavior the 2014 alien isolation
video game
employ artificial intelligence to follow
the player around all the time two
artificial intelligence systems are used
in the game one is the director
artificial intelligence who frequently
knows where you are and the alien
artificial intelligence which is
controlled by sensors and behaviors and
constantly changes the player
next comes
artificial intelligence in healthcare
delays can be the difference between
life and death in the healthcare
industry artificial intelligence in
healthcare has the potential to help
providers in many areas of patient care
and operational procedures enabling them
to build on current solutions and solve
problems quickly
covet 19 has illuminated the process of
developing vaccine in order to create
and test new medicines drug
manufacturers are increasingly turning
to artificial intelligence solutions
like deep learning because there are so
many potential chemical combinations
creating new medications requires
processing a lot of data artificial
intelligence overcomes this difficulty
by utilizing its exceptional performance
with massive amounts of data this
capability results in a higher
production of approved pharmaceuticals
in a more rapid less expensive and more
effective research and development
procedure
robotics another area where artificial
intelligence is frequently applied is
robotic
ai powered robots employ real-time
updates to detect obstructions in their
path and instantaneously design their
routes robotics uses artificial
intelligence to make machines more
intelligent and capable of acting in
variety of situations
robots can also sense their environment
or take in its views with the use of
sensor similar to how humans have
primary sensors robotics uses a variety
of sensing technology combined there is
a definite trend toward mobile
autonomous robots that can intelligently
gather process and manage data in order
to make the best decisions for
manufacturing or production
ai in banking the use of advanced data
analytics by artificial intelligence
will transform banking in the future by
reducing
fraud enhancing compliance
anti-money laundering tasks that would
typically take hours or days can now be
completed in a matter of seconds thanks
to artificial intelligence algorithms
erica a virtual assistant created by
bank of america is among the best
instances of artificial intelligence
chatbots in banking applications this
artificial intelligence chatbot can take
care of tasks like updating card
security and reducing credit card debt
daily life use of artificial
intelligence
autonomous vehicle to teach computers to
think and evolve like humans when it
comes to driving in any environment and
object recognition to prevent accidents
companies like toyota audi tesla use
machine learning algorithms
spam filters the email that we regularly
use features artificial intelligence
that separates out junk emails and sends
it to spam or trash folders allowing us
to see only the filtered material gmail
a well-known email service has achieved
a filtration capacity of roughly
99.9 percent
next comes facial recognition
facial recognition algorithms are used
by our favorite devices including phones
laptops and personal computers to detect
and identify users in order to grant
safe access
education sector artificial intelligence
can assist educators with
non-educational tasks such as
facilitating and automating personalized
messages to students back office duties
such as grading paperwork organizing and
facilitating
routine feedback
managing enrollment courses etc
a student can receive additional
learning resources or assistance with
voice assistance even without the
lecturer or teacher's direct engagement
this lowers the expense of producing
temporary handbooks and makes it simple
to provide answer to frequently asked
topics
artificial intelligence is most commonly
used in the field of e-commerce during
personalized shopping recommendation
engines are made possible by artificial
intelligence technologies allowing you
to interact with your customers more
effectively their browsing history
preferences and interest are taken into
consideration while making these
recommendations
it helps you build stronger bonds with
your clients and increases brand loyalty
for instance almost every page of
amazon's website offers personalized
product recommendations
credit card frauds fake reviews are two
most of the significant issues that
e-commerce companies deal with by
considering the usage patterns
artificial intelligence can help reduce
the possibility of credit card frauds
taking place
many customers prefer to buy a product
or service based on customer reviews
artificial intelligence can identify and
handle fake reviews
what is the answer to the question that
i have asked about artificial
intelligence assistant
they can be google assistant siri alexa
etc
moving on
in the area of artificial intelligence
significant advancement have been made
and the results are clear ai is a
flexible tool that is applied across
sectors to improve decision making boost
efficiency and get rid of repeated tasks
thank you for watching the video happy
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here